when most people think of the vietcong
and their allies Sweden doesn't often
make the list yet throughout the Vietnam
War Sweden was a supporter of theirs and
harshly critical of the United States
which raises the question why why did
Sweden site with the Vietcong so during
the Cold War Sweden aimed for a policy
of non-aligned seen peace neutrality in
war that is they weren't picking sides
however throughout most of this period
it was pretty clear that Sweden learned
much more towards the NATO camp than
that of the Warsaw Pact yet there were
many issues in which Sweden was
consistent in his criticism of the USA
in the West and one such issue was the
Vietnam War the Vietnam War had two
phases the first was when France the
colonial overlord of this area called
French Indochina Ford to quell a
rebellion against its rule now at first
the USA wasn't all too fussed about this
since he had no desire to preserve old
European empires but with Vietnam there
was an issue because in peace talks it
was divided into two states and North
Vietnam was under the control of
Communists and they wanted the South too
and as such it was intervention time
because domino theory dictated that all
instances of a potential communist
government must be stopped lest the
entire world fall to it so in the
mid-1960s Sweden pushed itself as an
international mediator and spent three
years trying to get the USA North
Vietnam to make peace this effort came
to an abrupt stop in 1968 when American
president lyndon b johnson told sweden
to mind its own business the next year
olaf palmer was elected a swedish prime
minister in his attitude towards the
vietnam war was much more hostile you
should know that he was a firm critic of
many foreign nations at this point so
the USA wasn't being specifically
targeted however he was extremely public
with his critiques such as when in 1972
he compared the u.s. bombing campaigns
in vietnam to germany's use of
concentration camps in world war ii and
in response the united states promptly
broke off diplomatic relations were
sweden until the next year so sweden
support for North Vietnam and the
Vietcong was because Palmer and the rest
of the Swedish governments or US
intervention is ignoring the will of the
people there thus making it an act of
imperialism now Palmer wasn't a
communist or anything it was mostly
driven by a fierce anti-war ideology
these criticisms ultimately changed
nothing and so Palmer opted to give
direct aid to the Vietcong now obviously
this didn't include sending a bunch of
Swedish shoulders to Vietnam to fight
the Americans or anything
what Sweden did was Kurt as close to how
as they could without drawing the wrath
of NATO and the first thing that Parma
did was to give asylum to American draft
dodgers the second thing Sweden did was
to send medical supplies to Vietnam
along with doctors to Train Vietcong
medics outside of the government many
Swedes were fiercely Pro Vietcong and
there was even an attempt by members of
the public to send money to North
Vietnam to acquire weapons in the end
Sweden support for the Vietcong was more
focused on its opposition to America's
war against it whilst the government did
recognize North Vietnam as an
independent country send it medical
supplies and give asylum to American
draft dodgers this was done from a
position of pacifism Sweden supported
the Vietcong against the United States
because it would have supported anyone
in the same situation against any other
great power which was a position that
Sweden would hold many more times
throughout the Cold War I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with the special thanks to my
patreon supporters James Bissonnette
calling Castleman Danny Maloney Marvin
Castle Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron
the white Michael Reynolds James
Castaneda Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma
Jordan Longley James Castaneda Gustav
Swann Marcus Arthur Jordan Hong Lei
Gareth Turner mr. show Rashid Ali
spinning three crates filled two oink
oink David Silverman
Izzy winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski
Lexi Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye's Chappell and
Anthony Beckett